c'est le carrefour de tous les fast food
sur l'un des axes les plus fréquentés de
lille voyant passer chaque jour
plusieurs dizaines de milliers de
clients potentiels pas moins de quatre
enseignes de restauration rapide
alors pour certains difficile de
résister combien grammaire et palettes à
la femme âgée le plus souvent ces
fast-foods paume oui oui on dit que
c'est pas bon c'est pas trop bon pour la
santé
bon parfois c'est pas pour le monde pour
la santé mais tu sais faire mais j'ai
vraiment rationnel et c'est pour me
dépanner plus tôt par facilité oui et
j'ai retiré par satellite est alors
devant les critiques récurrentes
les enseignes s'adaptent et proposent
dorénavant des menus moins caloriques
mais face au phénomène de la malbouffe
fleury surtout un type de restaurant
très en vue les bars à salades une
ethnie d'imagés utilisés pour pas
prendre trop de poids ne peut rester
comme je suis
est-ce que c'est difficile de s'habituer
finalement après à ce genre de repas
sains alors franchement pour faire de
gros efforts à ce que saab est chargé
comme ça équilibre est vraiment il faut
faire de gros efforts habituellement je
sais la voix n'a cédé à s'équilibrer
dans toujours dépoter
les légumes et
les choses couilles les choses puis du
bpo on essaie de faire moins ce qu au
bcm un peu de soupe aussi ça c'est
habituellement en tout et on en sait non
c'est le chaos
mais cette restauratrice de fort de
france ne se reconnaît ni dans l'une ni
dans l'autre de ses habitudes
alimentaires pour elle rien ne remplace
les bonnes assiettes d'antan ce que l'on
appelle communément la cuisine de
grand-mère avait les bons manger local
fouilles harper de légumes l'igname du
poisson de l'avion même en temps de
carême il n'y avait pas la viande c'est
le poisson
maintenant les gens moi je cogne à la
viande
des études ont montré que bousez
habitudes alimentaires varient en
fonction du sexe de l'âge et même du
lieu de résidence
quant à la consommation quotidienne de
fruits et légumes et les morts de base
d'une bonne nutrition
elle ne serait suffisante que pour un
martiniquais sur quatre